the lone star state of texas unveiling
the first stretch of the state-funded
border wall as joe biden's immigration
crisis spirals out of control as we've
been talking about here with more on his
state's efforts to keep their borders
safe texas land commissioner running for
attorney general of the state george p
bush george good morning to you
good morning so explain how this would
work i know that as soon as joe biden
came into office he pulled the plug on
donald trump's efforts to build a wall
now what are you guys going to do
so one of my first acts of office this
year at the land commission was to
survey the entirety of what the state
owned in the border lands of our great
state over 1200 miles of stretch and so
as it turns out over 200 000 acres uh
managed by my agency at or near the
border and in partnership with the texas
facilities commission the governor's
office and the texas legislature we went
to work knowing that the bind
administration wouldn't do their job so
we were proud to announce on saturday
morning that it was the people of texas
on state-owned land where we finally
said enough is enough enough for the
open borders policy enough of the record
spike in violent crime and drug
smuggling that we've seen in border
communities in texas and we're going to
take matters into our own hands knowing
that in the next three years we're not
going to get assistance from the federal
government on this issue so we're
excited with the first stretch of wall
that is being constructed to address one
of the most trafficked corridors of
violence that you'll find in our entire
state a two-mile stretch where over a
hundred migrants come across on an on a
daily basis and we look to engage with
private landowners and ranchers so that
they can be a part of this effort as
well okay and and you just touched on
something there at the end you're gonna
engage with private land owners and
ranchers because they really hold the
key in helping the state of texas finish
that wall
that's correct most of the border is
owned privately
pursuant to operation lone star which is
the governor's initiative to arrest
people under criminal trespassing
statute
requires engagement with private
ranchers land owners to sign affidavits
and in this case for wall construction
easements that allow us to further
construct because we have a lot of the
former contractors during the trump days
we have the funding from the building
behind me to to get to work i think my
agency along with the facilities
commission the governor's office would
now like to sign
more deals with private landowners so
that they can be a part of this i just
wrapped up a week-long tour of the
border from el paso to mcallen and some
land owners are asking can i shoot can i
shoot to
to basically withstand the amount of
surge that we're seeing and of course we
want a more peaceful approach to this
but building walls work that's what
border patrol tells us and we would love
for the private community to be a part
of this effort now when you say can i
shoot you mean
can i use uh have a firearm to protect
my family or what do you mean by that
that is correct for the you know
when you talk to farmers and ranchers a
lot of them describe a kinder gentler
illegal immigration pattern in prior
generations but now it has reached such
a heightened level of violence and
insecurity where farmers and ranchers
including the one where we just built
the first part of that wall
are now threatened on their own acreage
and around their own property and and
that's just that's un-american and we
need a state like ours to step forward
and continue this effort and speaking of
your state you want to be the attorney
general you're running for that uh why
why do you want that job
well i think we need to continue this
effort
i think unfortunately ken has been
sleeping at the wheel to backstop our
law enforcement operation lone star
which is apprehending detaining and
jailing illegal immigrants in her
criminal trespassing statutes but he
hasn't backstop
our local county attorneys and da's with
the necessary resources to get the job
done look the federal government has a
catch and release policy in texas we
need to stand for a catch in jail policy
so i'm going to fight for the border law
enforcement human trafficking and
restore integrity to this important
office all right he's george p bush
joining us today from austin running for
attorney general george thank you very
much have a great holiday christmas week
merry christmas